foreign
Jake is with us in Tampa Florida hi Jake
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave how are you today better than I
deserve what's up
um so I'm you know I've been following
the podcast and um I'm really ready to
grab you know the bull by the horns here
and really get cranking on uh this debt
that me and my wife has but I'm finding
that she's very fearful of the process
so much so where she's almost getting
paralyzed with deer and you know doing
nothing instead of you know getting
after it basically what's she afraid of
um she's afraid of Dipping into the
savings
um getting rid of our vehicles to you
know get cheaper ones worrying about
them breaking down you know a cheaper
vehicle breaking down that sort of thing
and you know I'm I'm really trying to
get going here she's fine with putting a
little bit of extra money towards credit
cards but anything major like that she
just she just can't um seem to get past
it so you've got a you've got a lump of
cash sitting there that you've been
saving up and you're wanting to put it
on the debt and that's making her feel
funky is that right yeah well lump is a
word for it it's only about five
thousand dollars but um
you know it's better than nothing
what was that how much you owe on your
car
well we have two trucks
um you're gonna kill me
30 39 000 loan on my pickup and we have
about 27 left on hers yeah what do you
guys make a year
you make about 130 A Year y'all are
freaking insane yeah
how old are you 26
uh 27 and my wife yeah like I've done
this before okay
wow
all right so what's happening is is that
you've recognized there's a problem and
that you're gonna that's a pretty ex
extreme problem and you're gonna have to
take some Extreme Measures to fix an
extreme problem and she hasn't even
recognized that there's an extreme
problem yet
yeah yeah I mean she knows there's a
problem
she does not think there is a problem
not like this oh we could pay a little
extra on the credit cards that doesn't
say there's a problem you guys are
freaking broke
you can't breathe
you got eighty thousand dollars worth of
stupid cars
uh-huh
oh my God yeah I mean
wow no I'm not gonna kill you I'm crying
for you it's scaring me I'm more scared
than your wife is and it's not even my
house
those cars is that the only debt or is
there more laying around
uh we got the truck and then we have uh
21 000 in credit cards oh yeah well of
course you do because you can't pay your
bills because you have car payments
so my guess is a lot of her fear you
guys have never gone through financial
peace you're you're picking this up from
listening to the show is that
am I right yeah yeah you know my wife or
um my mom used to have you know Dave on
the radio and I you know listen here and
there and I've you know I kind of
realized the predicament that a man and
I realize I really need to do something
here so my guess is that she you're just
relaying this information to her and she
might be getting bits and pieces of it
but she's not maybe heard it laid out in
the way that she needs to in order to
kind of trust this process and really
see that there's a problem it sounds
like you've been listening and your eyes
are wide open and she's still focused on
yeah but I want to be comfortable she's
she's still seeing comfort more than
she's seeing like the house is on fire
she doesn't see that yet
I smell smoke but I think you can put it
out yeah and you and I are like uh the
house is burning down around you uh-huh
yep you know we sat down we did our
budget and you know she knows the
numbers and you know we we went through
all of that but it just
it just seems to be affecting me more
and uh yeah because she thinks that is
normal you cannot you cannot start this
until she is
um
is as informed and as enthused about
cleaning up this mess as you are because
it's you're it's simply not going to
work
because it's not that she's afraid it's
that she's uninformed she does she does
not understand where you all are she may
have glanced at the numbers but she has
not swallowed them and put them in her
heart because otherwise she'd have
heartburn
[Music]
exactly yeah you guys need to sit down
and have a real conversation about this
and honestly you probably need to go
through Financial Peace University which
if Austin can pick up at the end of this
call he can give that to you because if
we give you that class nine week class
one class a week for nine weeks and even
if you took two a week for uh five weeks
and knocked it out well you started and
with her and can you get her to sit down
and watch this with you
um I can yes yes I can do it yeah okay
okay because it's better honey I need
you to do this as a favor to me this
stuff's driving me crazy you're not
worried about it but I can't sleep I
need your help please look at this with
me and let Dave and John and and all the
other Personalities in there be the one
to drive this message home and let them
be the bad guy no it's not a bad guy
it's not a bad guy we're all on the same
team here we all want one thing and
that's for Jake and his wife to prosper
we want them to win we love you we want
you to win we're not none of us are bad
guys you're not a bad guy she's not a
bad guy she just hasn't recognized where
she is yet that's right and once she
because I want her so fired up that
she's like Jake why haven't you already
sold your truck right but if if he's the
one going in every night and it's like
honey we need to do this which she's
gonna be like so let us be the one to
tell her if she once she catches the
vision of this she doesn't have the
vision for it that's all it is and once
she catches the vision for it then it's
not fear fear is not the right word it's
she simply doesn't want to do it
oh
that yeah she's not afraid she's just
saying no she likes being able to go and
swipe that credit card I like this I
like this 30 000 car why would I not
like it yeah no until you figure out
that your dad gum right on the verge of
bankruptcy yeah nobody wants to go from
a nice forty thousand dollar card to a
to an old 8 000 like that doesn't feel
good but you gotta do it yeah I mean
when when your best idea is honey we're
gonna sell your car that usually doesn't
go well yeah so
um but yeah both of these cars got to go
and you all are going to get home beans
and rice and you're gonna learn to live
on listen you make you make too much
money to be this broke we need to get
both of you need to get disgusted once
you guys get out of these trucks this is
gonna go lickety-split these trucks are
the problem the credit cards are not
there because of credit card spending
the credit cards are there because they
can't afford to live after they pay
these truck payments yeah that's what it
is they're squeezed yeah that's been the
credit cards picking up the slack so
when there is no slack then boom you
know you'll knock them out and you're
you're gonna have this mess cleaned up
once you get rid of these ridiculous
vehicles
um but yeah you it's you don't have a
truck that needs to be amputated you
have a truck amputation coming in